great thank you amazing just in time for
that whopper of a trailer to drop on us
season 10 when you saw that what was
your reaction to it all play out he's
gonna get shipped out of the damn
country I don't know if I'm ready to let
him go my family like we saw those phone
calls with Joe and the trailer watching
those scenes back how did you feel
[Music]
that's your personal business with my
father so enough it might be the most
dramatic season yet we're gonna have to
watch you and your family go through a
lot yeah I know we're all anxiously
awaiting to find out what's gonna happen
how are you doing right now
I know we see gia really step up this in
the trailer at least for this season to
talk to through some of this stuff
how's she kind of in your walk through
this like how are the girls doing
they're pretty amazing
you know strong young women I guess they
get it from their mommy
keeping hopes high we saw rumors that
Joe wants to become an MMA fighter if
when he finally gets out is that true I
guess yeah I know we're waiting
hopefully gets to come home do we know
when that's gonna be when we're gonna
get the answer
Margaret's the reason we went through a
divorce Marnie I'm not letting you go
back to her that [ __ ] needs to be put
on mute oh don't be digging for gold
picture so seems like Danielle is in the
middle of a lot of drama you're gonna
have to watch season 10 versus
cocktailing it up all night with some
young guy okay I was cheating Teresa
she's out of control but it's also like
there's questions of your fidelity
having to deal with that in the public
eye how do you deal with that I'm used
to it yeah that's what happens when
you're on TV the double-edged sword
watch your back [ __ ] are you in a good
place with all those ladies though going
okay give me one word for this season
what's one word for season 10 one word
Wow I would say Wow
[Music]
[Applause]